non non non et non je ne saura jamais
vous trop petit canard en soit on m'a
menti deux ans j'avais bien m'occuper de
moi
au secours julie julie joly hm ouhlala
elle n'est pas là trois soirs il n'est
pas là non plus mais c'est affreux
on s'était souvent table je suis tout
simplement tu n'es pas tout seul mon
petit canard orange sachant tiède mais
fêter la demie diaz et fais toi
les laissez moi mais c'est moi je dois
vous dire mon loisel futé comprend
clairement je ne suis pas un petit
poussin aussi mystique
deuxièmement je ne suis pas un petit
mouton frisé réussi mais si je ne suis
pas non plus posera petit canard orange
il est il guéri quatrièmement je tiens à
vous dire que je suis un gros monstre
issu d'une grande famille de monstres
préhistoriques et je tiens à rester ce
que je suis mais moi je sais que tu en
souffrent mais non petit manque
d'affection mais fera du tout mais je
suis certaine que tu fais des cauchemars
toutes les nuits moi pas du tout fait de
très beaux rêves dans lesquels on
retrouve tous mes amis tu oserait me
promettre que tu ne fais jamais de
touche marc moi je n'en fais jamais nous
enfin soient fins et aux biens sauf
quand le soir j manche et deux énormes
gloubiboulga pour mon dîner à tu vois je
vais te préparer une tisane
oui je ne veux pas de tisanes et bien
bien que se passe t-il laissé aux
madmoizelles edmée fumée quelle surprise
futé pardon parfumé futaie je m'appelle
et de mes chutes au port dont
mademoiselle excuses c'est moche de la
saison nous la menons avec plaisir
oh excusez moi mais je sais je sais
malgré elle vous avez horreur des
poignées de main molle j'avais
complètement oublié
françois il faut que tu me protège j'ai
peur comment tu as peur toi casimir le
plus fort de tous les êtres vivants dans
l'île aux enfants mais miss c'est elle
qui me fait peur mademoiselle futé mais
pourquoi kg mais le pass elle veut
m'emmener avec 1
la wii que gémir et malheureux dans
cette jungle devenir malheureux j'en
suis certaine j'ai donc résolu de le
rendre heureux
j'ai décidé de l'emmener avec moi pour
qu'il soit enfin je voyais dorloter où
je vais m'occuper de lui avec le
dévouement d'une main mais j'ai déjà
mère c'est pas vrai mais si nouvelle
elle vit de ce côté de lille dans le
bois et casimir us
je ne peux le croire et de plus casimir
a plein d'amis dans notre île vous
l'aimez oui et même de très bons amis
il y à france soir et il y à julie il ya
le facteur même un monsieur du ch ob
et puis il ya tous les enfants aussi là
ça c'est bien vrai casino où tous les
enfants mais mais alors quasi mais on
n'est pas malheureux du tout casimir est
très heureux dans l'île aux enfants sa
femme une heure quand j'essaie de vous
l'expliquer aux mais c'est épouvantable
je suis venu jusqu'ici pour rien pas du
tout mademoiselle parlez nous de vos
derniers trains ça vous intéresse
vraiment mais bien sûr eh bien je suis
chargé un travail très important sur les
fruits à pépins et les fouilles à noyaux
auriez vous les connaissez tous pas
encore en jeu là vous nous l appelons
les enfants ils vont sûrement vous et
votre arrivée l'union les enfants nés il
on va vous venez vous divertir en géant
j'ai dit vous allez voir ça va être
passionnant
allez on va voir ce que l'on savait
autant que mademoiselle futé je vous
présente ma demoiselle futé alors vous
allez dès l'annoncé de fuites est à
trouver le plus grand nombre possible de
fruits avec des pépins et avec des
noyaux vous avez compris
pépin ou noyau noyau alors qu'il ya des
réponses
patrick c'est quoi une poire pépin yoyo
des pins noter une foire il ya des
pépins c'était ça cérium une pêche oui
c'est des noyaux d'abricot l'ex capitale
c'est juste un bon j'ai une pomme pépin
et pain ou des peintures et 1,11
unifamiliales a dépeint oui mandarine
mais paris c'est meilleur quand il n'a
pas trop d yvonne et éteindre une partie
de raisin c'est des noyaux williams une
pomme et e on l'avait déjà dit ça risa
raisin et fun myriam tienne réponse un
abricot à bout s'était déjà dit myriam
les langues
vous n'etes emmanuel françois roth noyau
disent langues
oui casimir annan alors bon bah vous
fait rire
these mieux je crois que tu es un petit
peu étourdi on avez vous suffisamment
même de cette fuite est et bien oui
comme ça c'est très bien eh bien nous
vous remercions tous cela nous a donné
un jeu bien amusant et bien je vous
remercie et j'ai terminé mon travail
merci à toi casimir casimir wade
qu'as-tu pensé de ce jeu et bien moi
j'ai appris des noms de fruits très
intéressant de quelle fuir tu parles et
casimir est bien quand mademoiselle
futin reviendra me chercher pour
m'emmener le moins de livres aux enfants
et je lui flanque rails une pêche dans
la poire
et elle tombera dans les pommes
quasiment